let's talk about the biggest comedian in
America literally and figuratively rush
limbaugh actually this is bizarrely good
news related to rush he has sort of come
around and is now accepting that gay
marriage is going to happen in this
country
he doesn't really back it himself but he
now sees it as in it and inevitability
tough word but let's listen to Russia
so my conclusion that gay marriage is
inevitable was simply in recognition of
what the political story said that the
Republican Party wishes it would go away
and that didn't by that they mean the
Supreme Court issue a sweeping ruling
legalizing in all 50 states
if the primary source of pushback isn't
going to push back I'm sorry it's
inevitable inevitable
there you go doesn't sound too happy
about it Matt is it inevitable and if
you've won Rush Limbaugh have you
actually won the argument well I think
there are two different two different
answers to those questions um
one I do think it's inevitable and I
think you can really gauge the community
you know the community consensus on it
at this point that there's just been the
velocity of which people you know the
people the people have people have
adopted this view over the last it's a
eighteen to twenty-four months it's
pretty unparalleled and even it's in
2008 you didn't feel like the tide had
really turned and that it was starting
to spread into you know kind of the
voters and the the people in the
populace were in between the 40-yard
lines but it was still more of you know
cut it still more a play of a of an
interest group and so I think that you
know just not taking the not Rush
Limbaugh perspective you can see that
you know it's if anything is going at
this rate and you know at this rate it's
going to you know eventually the
holdouts are not gonna be able to stem
the tide any longer now putting that
placing that up against Rush Limbaugh
and why he's adopting this view I think
it's really just a common Rush Limbaugh
tactic of exasperation and that he's
throwing his hands up and showing how
he and the other traditional Americans
are with you know how everything's going
to hell and how basically good wholesome
Americans have been put under the spell
of these liberal interest groups and
whenever he gets to latch on to that you
know he really hits it up he really hits
that home because just kind of
solidifies you know the kind of cultural
leanings of his audience and that's all
those only people who really cares about
he's not looking to appeal beyond his
audience so adopting this view it allows
him to do so without looking like he's
so [ __ ] that he can't see what's
right in front of us yes Sam is there
anything worse than these liberal
interest groups that just want equality
for their liberal basis it's
unbelievable to me especially because
when you look at what surprises me about
Rush Limbaugh's even you know prior to
the statement when he talks about the
sanctity of marriage he's the last
person to talk he's been married four
times so you know that to me is just
absolutely surprising and and and you
know like you said I mean I don't think
I think marriage equality shouldn't be a
political issue it's a human rights
issue so sure rush limbaugh and and
other people that are conservative or
are very religious you can have your
opinion you can have your belief and say
listen I do not agree that same-sex
couples should be able to marry that's
fine I respect that I highly disagree
with you but to then try and govern an
individual and say that you do not have
this right to get married like every
other human being out there that to me
is immoral yeah bill when we look back
what once gay marriage is legalized
whether it takes two years or five years
or ten years when we look back on the
people like Rush Limbaugh and the Rick
Santorum's and the Michele Bachmann's
and that whole gang well we look back on
them the way we look back on people that
were for segregation back in the 50s is
it going to be that level of scrutiny
III think it all depends on what we're
not rush actually comes out and gets
married to another yeah maybe that's why
he's giving up baby that's why he thinks
it's a never maybe it's a personal
choice he thinks the fifth wife will be
of the same gender first yeah maybe Newt
you're on the record so you don't think
that we're gonna look back at all we're
gonna look back at all that footage
absolutely yes a very hilarious mashup
just a few years yeah
do any of you guys think that this thing
isn't gonna happen in the next you know
in the short foreseeable future two or
two or three years you know I did two or
three years at tops I you know it's odd
that there's a real distinction between
I mean I'm 31
every generation below me starting with
probably anyone who's 28 and younger and
this is second nature to them and I just
I I think you rarely see you know
culture kind of cultural norms evolve at
this rate and I think you know gay
marriage and the acceptance of
homosexuality over the last few years is
you know real outlier not in a bad sense
but you know it's I think the
Republicans realize that thump some of
the part of what's going on with Rush
Limbaugh is that he sees that the
Republican mainstream and the
establishment is trying to pawn off a
lot of their recent failures on him and
he knows that this one this would be
easy Father for them to say look you've
got the Rush Limbaugh's you know making
us lose the youth vote because they're
railing against gay marriage and now he
gets to kind of buttress that a little
bit funny that you know radio hosts have
to sort of act like politicians because
you're right he's playing to the base
the same way in the base you know he's
letting me know to give up on the to
give up on the issue because there
there's no way they can survive as a
party unless they unless they do really
interesting backpedaling going on there
I went on some of the forums and a lot
of his fan base and cleaning himself
there's like an another updated
interview where he started a backpedal
because his a large part of his fan base
was saying no this is this is you know
you this is against the Bible this is
against religion and it's so funny
because they're so quick to use the
Bible in certain aspects of it that suit
their agenda because you know there's
other out worldly things in the Bible
like you know you should send your
firstborn daughter in slavery so it's
like it's it's their eye they go ahead
and they pick and choose which agenda
it's we preach either
just so pretty so literal so I thought
it was interesting though watching him
kind of do like an update within the
forums because so many people did not
like that he was kind of you know
lifting up his arms and saying this is
inevitable yeah well rush if you do
officially officially get behind gay
marriage you would be the biggest star
in the gay bear bars of West Hollywood
vinolas calm is the official outfitter
of the Rueben report use code TR r20 to
get this shirt and these jeans